MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Vogelzwitschern,
hüpfende, elektronische Klänge *
Arthur und Deborah sind endlich in
der langersehnten Wildnis angekommen.
Unterwegs mit Interrail.
We have a bicycle
for washing your clothes.
Ein Liebespaar, beste Kumpels ...
Ich will keine Schlägerei wegen dir,
David, wirklich nicht.
... und zwei Freundinnen ...
Ich sage Mama nicht, mir sei kalt -
sonst sagt sie: "Sagte ich ja."
... reisen einen Monat mit dem Zug
von Abenteuer zu Abenteuer.
* Hüpfende, elektronische Klänge *
Wow!
* Stimmengewirr, Saxofonmusik *
Okay, ich hasse Wind.
(Grinsend) Blow job, der Reiter ...
Der Reiter ...
Das ist ja mal geil.
* Beide lachen. *
Wir haben im Nachtzug
eine Amerikanerin kennengelernt.
Und dann ...
Dann haben wir uns mit ihr getroffen
in diesem Industriegebiet.
Dann gingen wir mit ihr essen.
Wir sind etwas rumgelaufen
und jetzt trinken wir noch etwas.
Was, ist das unser Kollege?
Unser Kollege rudert doch nicht,
der hat einen Motor.
Hello!
Deborah und Arthur
kriegen unerwarteten Besuch
des Einheimischen,
der sie auf die Insel gebracht hatte.
* Weiche Saiteninstrumentklänge *
No, I will take this.
Okay, thank you.
Mh.
* Grillen *
Jetzt sind wir wieder einsam
und allein auf unserer Insel.
Ja, schön.
Die machen das nicht zum ersten Mal.
* Rhythmische Rockmusik *
Das ist so komisch.
Die Jungs tauchen beim VR-Game
in neue Welten ein.
Unterwegs
sind sie jetzt nur virtuell.
Luca, wo bist du?
- Was?
Wo bist du, Luca?
- Ich weiss nicht.
O mein Gott, es ist so komisch.
Ich kann in mich reinschauen.
Bro, bist das du?
O mein Gott.
Shit,
jetzt wäre ich fast runtergefallen.
* Beide lachen. *
Oh!
Hey, wo seid ihr?
(Luca) Uh, das war Elias.
* Lachen *
Lol.
Are you okay?
- Ach, hier stehe ich? Lol.
Okay, I'm going to take this off.
Alter, das war so wirr.
Hey.
Gut gemacht.
- Das war gut.
Wir können uns mal so umarmen.
Das fühlt sich besser an.
- Das war komisch.
Ob es statt auf Interrail
nächstes Jahr nach Kalifornien geht?
Hummus. So geil.
Oh, Algensalat in der Mitte!
Dafür diese hier.
Oh, ja.
- Nicht?
Ah, was ist das?
Nicht wahr?
- Nein, nicht gut.
Bist du enttäuscht?
- Irgendwie schon.
Wir haben halt kein Avocado-Sushi.
Es ist so schön.
- Fünf Tage sind nichts.
Wirklich nichts.
Ich bin traurig, heimzugehen.
Ich auch.
- Sie sollen hierhinkommen.
Finde ich auch,
dann müssen wir nicht heim. - Ja.
Ey, Mann, ey.
* Weiche, langsame Celloklänge *
Es ist so kalt. Ist dir auch kalt?
Mit der Jeansjacke geht es.
- Stimmt, du hast die Jeansjacke.
Ah!
Ich sage meiner Mutter nicht,
dass mir kalt ist.
Sonst sagt sie:
"Sagte ich dir doch."
* Weiche, langsame Celloklänge *
Nach drei Nächten auf der Insel
verlassen die beiden ihre Idylle.
Zurück in die Zivilisation.
Okay, ich springe.
- Du springst.
Hu. Okay.
* Stimmengewirr *
* Möwenrufe *
* Melancholische Gitarrenmelodie *
Während die einen in Krakau
im Airbnb kochen müssen,
ist Luc schon in die gemeinsame
Wohnung in Bern gezogen.
Luc ruft an.
Luc.
Hallo.
(Krächzend) Hallo, hallo.
Wer ist alles bei uns?
Jetzt seht ihr wohl nichts.
Nein, ich sehe nichts.
* Sie reden durcheinander. *
Hoi.
(Frau) Wer ist da? Luca?
- Ja.
Hoi, Luca.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Der Balkon ist voll.
Die wohnen jetzt alle bei uns?
Ja, genau.
- Das ist gut.
Zuoberst steht das Boot
fürs Aareböötlen.
* Alle lachen. *
Das ist doch gut.
Das brauchen wir sicher als Erstes.
Gekocht haben wir auch schon.
- Gut.
Ja.
- Ja.
(Frau) Luca, du siehst gut aus!
- Danke. Zeig mal!
(Frau) Ja, finde ich auch.
Du auch.
- Alle finden es.
Deine Augenbrauen
kommen gut zur Geltung.
Gute Nacht.
- Schlaft gut.
Tschau.
Luc, das ist für dich.
* Kussgeräusch *
Luc.
Die leben sich jetzt
einfach in unserer Wohnung ein,
und wir sind nicht mal dort.
Die haben jetzt schon
ein Riesenfest,
und wenn wir erst zurück sind ...
Das gibt
ein noch viel grösseres Fest.
Dort wird's noch einige Feste geben.
* Pulsierende Elektromusik
dringt nach aussen. *
# Everybody dance now!
Fuck! O mein Gott,
ich hatte solches Glück.
Wieso meinst du?
Dass er mich nicht
in meinem schönen Gesicht erwischte.
Sonst hätte ich blaue Flecken.
* Sie lachen. *
Aber wieso machst du solchen
Scheiss? - Es war super lustig.
Ich habe es verdient.
Ich habe 2 Std. lang
so ID-Kontrolle gemacht.
So: "ID, please."
Das hat funktioniert.
Deshalb muss er dir
trotzdem nicht Fäuste geben.
Ja, das war so daneben.
- Daneben. Von ihm und von dir.
Denn ich weiss:
Wenn du in eine Schlägerei gerätst,
verteidige ich dich - egal, was ist.
Und Elias auch.
Aber ich mag echt nicht
in eine Schlägerei geraten, David.
Das muss man jetzt
nicht so eng sehen.
Nein, nein.
O mein Gott.
- Was?
Muriel hat auch bestanden.
O mein Gott.
Ich schreibe meiner Nachbarin.
Do it.
Ich halte es nicht mehr aus.
Hat sie geschrieben?
- (Leise) Nein.
Hat sie es gesehen?
- (Verzweifelt) Nein.
Gestern um 16 Uhr
war sie zuletzt online.
Schau aufs Handy!
Sie ist online, o mein Gott.
Mein Herz klopft auch wie wild.
Was denkst du?
- Ich will Tierärztin werden.
O mein Gott. Sie ist online.
Du hast bestanden, Francesca!
Was steht hier?
"Wir haben ... dass wir Sie für
das Studienjahr zuteilen können."
O mein Gott, ich habe bestanden!
O mein Gott!
Ja!
Nein, warte. Wirklich?
- Ja!
You did it!
- O mein Gott, ich hab's geschafft.
Ich bin so stolz auf dich.
Ich wusste es. - O Gott.
Hoi, Francesca.
- Hoi, Papi.
Und?
- Ich habe bestanden!
* Jubel *
(Frau, italienisch)
Wow, du machst mich überglücklich.
- Ich bin auch überglücklich.
* Jubel *
Heute Abend
machen wir einen Pubcrawl.
Ja, ja, ja.
Yes!
(Englisch)
Cheers!
(Frau) There we go.
* Discomusik:
"La Macarena" von Los Del Rio *
* Rhythmischer Partysong: "Can't Hold
Us" von Macklemore und Ryan Lewis *
Mir ist übel.
- Nein!
Ich habe so viel gegessen.
- Nachher trinkst du nichts mehr.
Willst du Wasser?
- Nein, ist gut.
Ich bin so voll.
* Fernöstliche, klimpernde Klänge *
Deborah und Arthur sind unterwegs
zum Ökodorf in Griechenland.
Dort wollen sie mithelfen,
das Dorf aufzubauen.
Sollen wir mal rufen?
Hello?
Hello!
- Oh.
Hello.
- Hi, there.
Hi.
If you need a hand with anything ...
(Frau) Now make a hole.
Take a stick.
* Leise Gespräche, Lachen *
* Weiche, sanfte Klänge *
Nice.
Hier wird eine Bühne
für ein Elektrofestival gebaut,
das im Sommer 2020 stattfinden wird.
* Leise Gespräche, Lachen *
It's cool from up here.
(Frau) Watch out!
* Leise Radiomusik *
* Hämmern *
* Bohrmaschine, Säge *
Wow!
- Wow.
So schön.
Wieso ist das Meer dort so braun?
Es sieht wirklich ziemlich ...
Hauptsache erst mal motzen.
- Klar, muss man.
Genau darauf habe ich mich gefreut.
Breiten wir hier unsere Tücher aus?
Ja, breitet mal unsere Tücher aus.
Ist das schwarze Ding dein Tuch?
- Nein, das ist mein Pulli.
Ich habe es dir extra gesagt, Luca.
Dann habe ich gesagt:
"Nein, nimm du mit."
Ich habe auch kein grosses.
- Also, es reicht für mich.
* Drollige Akkordeonklänge *
Mh.
- Hallo.
Die Dusche war noch kälter
als das Meer. - Echt?
Wer geht ohne Tuch zum Strand?
* Lachen *
Luca.
Du hast das Tichu
wohl auch nicht mitgenommen.
Mein Portemonnaie,
mein Handy, meine Sonnenbrille ...
Ich höre nur: "Meins, meins, meins."
Und ... so ein Pulli.
... so einen komischen
habe ich mitgenommen.
Was hast du denn mitgenommen?
Ein Handy, einen Plastiksack
für unsere nassen Sachen,
ein Tuch, um uns abzutrocknen ...
ja.
Eine Tasche, in die wir unsere
Sachen tun können. - Also deine.
Was ist in der Tasche?
- Hauptsächlich meine Sachen.
Weil Luca kein Tuch mitnehmen
wollte, sonst wäre es auch da drin.
Nein, dann hätte ich
eine eigene Tasche mitgenommen.
Schon wieder: "Meins, meins, meins."
Weisst du, was lustig ist?
Du wolltest mir vorhin das Tuch
nicht geben - weil es ja deins ist.
So ist es. - Aber dann
gross posaunen, es sei unseres.
Ja.
Aber weil du ja bewusst keines ...
- Elias hat mir seins ausgeliehen.
... bewusst keines mitgenommen hast.
Da dachte ich,
du bist nicht darauf angewiesen.
Irgendwie ist diese Reise
nicht so speziell,
weil wir
schon so viel Zug gefahren sind.
Im Sinne: "Easy, machen wir
in 24 Std. Porto nach ..."
"... Frankreich."
Gell, vor 24 Std. ging's los.
Ja.
- Mehr als 24 Std.
Es fühlt sich nach weniger an,
nicht? - Mh.
Die letzte kurze Station ist Paris,
bevor es nach einigen Stunden
zurück nach Baar geht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Paris.
- Ich auch nicht.
Was denkst du bisher von Paris?
Hm. Es ist so ... mega touristisch.
- Jap.
Irgendwie: Dafür dass man sagt,
Paris sei die Stadt der Liebe,
hat es mir zu wenig ...
- Gell, es hat nicht so ...
... zu wenig Liebe.
If you know what I mean.
- I get you.
Ich hätte gedacht,
es sei mehr kaputt.
Eben, sie ist gar nicht so kaputt.
- Ja.
Nur ein kleiner Teil.
Sie konnten sie retten.
# Paris, mon amour.
# Je reste la, toujours.
Was hältst du davon?
- Nein, sie soll noch nichts sagen.
Schon komisch.
- Schon komisch, was?
Okay, girls. Ready.
So cool.
- Dein Piercing ist wirklich drauf.
Yeah, true.
Yay!
* Francesca lacht. *
Aber ich erkenne mich jetzt nicht.
- Ich mich auch nicht.
Also, er hätte Sommersprossen
machen können.
Nein, das lohnt sich nicht mehr.
- Zum Eiffelturm zu gehen?
Ja, wir haben keine Zeit.
15.20 Uhr fährt er.
Ich werde dich
heute Abend vermissen.
Ich auch.
"Francesca, komm zu mir!"
* Grillen *
Wenn jeder sich so bewusst wäre,
würde auch
freier Kapitalismus funktionieren.
Aber das ist meiner Meinung nach
eine Utopie, eine Wunschvorstellung.
Ja, aber ich glaube daran.
- Ja, ich auch, ich auch.
Deshalb lebe ich so.
- Ja, ich auch.
Für mich heisst es,
weniger zu konsumieren
und nichts zu tun,
das ich nicht brauche.
Ich brauche ganz vieles nicht.
Sobald ich nur das mache,
was ich brauche,
das wirklich wichtig ist,
das Essentielle,
habe ich auch viel mehr Zeit,
mir selbst bewusst zu sein.
Wenn ich nicht den ganzen Tag
am Handy hänge.
Wenn ich nicht immer
unnötig konsumiere,
meine Ferien nicht so gestalte,
dass ständig Aktivität ist,
sondern dass man auch Zeit hat,
einige Tage irgendwo zu sitzen
und nachzudenken.
Dann kommt doch erst der Geist auf,
etwas zu reflektieren.
Aber was weiss ich schon?
Ich bin nur ein 19-jähriger Schüler.
Aber ich stimme dir zu.
Das hast du gut gesagt.
Cheers.
Das sieht schon speziell aus.
Es sieht aus wie Flusswasser.
Hoi, hallo.
Es ist ein grosses Treffen
in Hamburg:
Davids Freundin und
ein Freund aus Bern stossen dazu.
Zusammen verbringen sie
die letzten Tage der Reise.
Geht's gut?
- Tipptopp.
Hoi!
Geht's gut?
- Mhm.
* Gespräche,
Musik aus einem Lautsprecher *
Morgen geht's nach Hause.
Dann sehen alle Luc wieder,
und der Umzug in die WG steht an.
Müde, aber glücklich, sind die beiden
nach vier Wochen wieder zusammen.
Was machst du?
* Langsame,
melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Auch das Europaabenteuer
von Deborah und Arthur
neigt sich dem Ende zu.
Die Natur und die Freiheit
haben sie hinter sich gelassen.
Es wird komisch,
wieder Schweizerdeutsch zu hören.
Ja.
Und es ist alles so geregelt.
- Voll.
Du hast deinen Job ...
- Alles ist genormt, funktioniert.
Es ist einfach kein Abenteuer mehr.
Im Balkan ist alles, was du machst,
ein Abenteuer.
Es passiert immer was,
jemand kommt auf einen zu ...
Hier ist es so voraussehbar.
- Voll.
Grau.
- Oh, nein.
Langweilig.
Tja, bringen wir den Balkan-Spirit
in die Schweiz.
Ja, wir müssen Farbe reinbringen.
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Hu!
- Nice.
Es ist echt nicht kalt.
Ich habe Eiseskälte erwartet.
Gell, du hast dich schon
in den Schal gewickelt.
Wir gehen zum Gleis 43/44
und steigen in irgendeinen Zug.
Schau nicht auf die Abfahrtstafel.
Wir steigen einfach ein.
Wir entscheiden spontan,
wo wir aussteigen.
Voll. Wir beginnen ein neues Leben.
Ja, wir haben genug dabei -
unsere Bohnen erhalten uns am Leben.
Ein Dreierzelt,
Isomatte, Schlafsack, alles.
Hey!
- Hey.
Ihr seid zurück!
- Je.
Zurück zum schlechten Wetter.
Konntet ihr keine Sonne mitbringen?
Hi.
- Hoi.
Hi. - Nicht umarmen,
ich stinke wie ein Tier.
Ich weiss, Deborah auch.
Hallo.
- Hi.
Ihr habt Glück,
wir haben warmes Wasser. - Nice.
Obwohl sie die Heizung machen.
- Lebensstandard in der Schweiz.
Habt ihr überhaupt noch Zeit
in Griechenland verbracht?
Schon noch fünf Tage.
Wir waren die ganze Zeit
im Eco Village.
Also ... Ah, doch!
Athen? - Nein,
wir kamen nicht bis nach Athen.
* Entspannte Musik
aus einem Lautsprecher *
In Bern ist man schon
im Umzugsfieber.
Die Freiheit der Jungs
beginnt ab sofort
in den ersten eigenen vier Wänden.
Hopp!
Soll ich raufkommen?
- Nein, ist gut.
Souverän. - Als hätten wir nie
was anderes gemacht.
Brauchen wir sonst noch was?
Ich habe eine Liste gemacht, auf der
wir solche Dinge notieren können.
Abwaschbürste.
- Wir haben Schwämme.
Ich kann es aufschreiben.
Man könnte die Schwämme
immer halbieren.
Man braucht keinen so Riesenschwamm.
Gut, wir haben so viele Schwämme.
- Trotzdem.
Ja ...
Gut, ich würde schon
den ganzen Schwamm ...
Wir können sie auch halbieren,
ist mir egal.
David?
- Ich lege mich etwas hin.
Ich nehme auch einen Powernap.
Auf das:
etwas Prinzessin-Lillifee-Tee.
Der ist super lecker.
- Er ist wirklich gut.
Mein Lieblingstee. Mein Mami
hat mir davon etwas eingepackt.
Verdammt gut.
Wasser auffüllen?
Ja.
Es gibt wieder Brunnen mit geilem
Wasser. - Schweizer Wasser.
O mein Gott,
wir sind schon in Thalwil.
Ich will nicht.
# Wish we could turn back time ...
# ... to the good old days.
Darf ich auch?
Francescas Eltern
sind noch im Urlaub.
Deshalb holt sie
ihr Freund, Jonas, ab.
Sorry, falls ich stinke.
48 Std. Zug fahren ...
Ein Monat ist nur okay.
Yeah, noch mal.
And cheese. Alle zusammen.
Let's go home!
Maya, komm.
- Mami will heim. Sie will essen.
Ich denke, du willst heim, oder?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
- Ich auch nicht.
Komm gut heim.
Und ... see you soon.
Mir ist gerade was eingefallen.
Huch, ja da riecht es ... stickig.
Hier kann ich
drei neue Länder freirubbeln.
Dann musst du noch in den Osten
und in den Norden.
Ja, Osten machen wir nächstes Jahr.
- Dann hast du Europa.
Ich will mit.
- Das sehen wir noch.
Maya und ich haben auch schon drüber
gesprochen: mit oder ohne Freund?
Wohl lieber ohne.
- Ja, wohl schon.
Nope.
* Sie quietscht. *
Jetzt hat es Francesca
schwarz auf weiss:
Ab September
darf sie Tiermedizin studieren.
Weisst du, was ich morgen
kochen möchte? - Was?
Crepes.
Ich hatte in Frankreich
nie gute Crepes.
18 Orte.
In vier Wochen.
Acht junge Menschen
haben einen Sommer lang
ihre eigene Freiheit auf Schienen
erlebt,
uns ihr Europa gezeigt und uns
fast alle ihre Geschichten erzählt.
Ich habe etwas Angst.
Nicht davor. Sondern ...
... wegen des Tattoos.
Mami weiss es noch nicht.
Schau.
Oh.
Sieht so gut aus.
- Thank you.
Mami weiss es nicht?
- Nein.
Ich weiss nicht. Jetzt
ist nicht der Moment. Oder doch?
Doch.
- Doch?
Ja, du bist zurück ...
Habt ihr
alle meine Postkarten erhalten?
(Mutter) Alle. Hast du gesehen?
- Monaco und Cannes.
Nizza ...
Ja, Dali, Toledo ...
Okay, nicht von jedem Ort.
Z.B. in Madrid gab's nur hässliche.
Wo willst du sitzen?
- An meinem Platz, oder.
Schon klar an ihrem Platz. - Noemi,
du kannst auch ans Ende sitzen.
* Die Mutter holt erstaunt Luft. *
Ist das Henna?
Es ist echt.
Ich habe es dir nicht gesagt.
Wow.
- Was?
Gefällt es dir?
You know what I think.
- Ja, aber weisst du was ...
Erstens liebe ich Blumen.
Zweitens sind es die Nationalblumen
jeden Landes, in dem wir waren.
Hast du recherchiert?
Spanien, Italien,
Frankreich, Portugal.
Okay.
Ich will auch schauen.
Es sieht so schön aus.
Es ist einfach unter der Haut.
Uh!
Es ist super schön gestochen.
- Wirklich schön. So fein.
Jetzt, da ich zurück bin, und lebe,
kann ich dir etwas erzählen, Mami.
Ich weiss was.
Ich weiss auch, was.
Ich durfte es dir nicht sagen, Mami.
Was?
- Nichts sehr Schlimmes.
In Barcelona
hatten wir erst ein Airbnb.
Ich erzählte ja,
dass wir wechselten. - Ja.
Aber nicht den Grund.
- Was?
Es war ein ... Drogenloch.
Es waren Drogensüchtige,
die die Wohnung
falsch im Internet ausschrieben.
Sonst wären wir
nicht dorthin gegangen.
Es war ein anderes Bild -
nicht vom Zimmer, in dem wir waren.
Eine andere Beschreibung ...
- Es hatte Kakerlaken.
Es hatte Kakerlaken,
Löcher in der Wand,
keine Küche, das WC war draussen.
Ja, voll.
* Elektronische, hüpfende Klänge *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Meret Hachen - 2019